two key components the first one being
our very own sun which we have an image
here of taken by NASA an image courtesy
of the Solar Dynamics Observatory with a
big beautiful bright sun with a lot of
texture on the surface there now the sun
is a huge ball of burning gas in our
skies or to be more precise plasma
electrically charged superheated gas and
the Sun is of course the source of all
the heat and light that we need here on
the earth to survive sitting at an
average distance of 150 million
kilometers away from us the sun is about
1.4 million kilometers in diameter it is
an absolute Behemoth capable of fitting
over one million Earths inside of it
now the second key component of an
eclipse is of course the moon our very
own natural satellite in orbit around
the Earth the Moon is about one quarter
the size of the Earth and orbits around
the earth once every
27.3 days now sometimes during that
orbit the moon is closer to us and
sometimes it is further away that's
because the moon's orbit is not
perfectly circular it is instead
elliptical which means sometimes it is
closer and sometimes it is further away
but on average the moon sits at a
distance from us of about 384
000 kilometers
so relatively close uh celestially
speaking so how does that actually end
up causing an eclipse where we've got an
animation here that can help to
visualize this a little bit better for
us so as the moon orbits around the
Earth
sometimes it will come directly between
the Earth and the Sun and when that
positioning is just correct just about
right we get solar eclipses
as the moon appears to cover the face of
the sun sometimes in its entirety in the
case of a total solar eclipse and
sometimes only partially in the case of
today the partial solar eclipse either
way the moon will cast a shadow onto the
surface of the Earth during a total
solar eclipse the darkest part of its
shadow the Umbra will pass over the
Earth and if you are within the path of
totality and you sit under the shadow
you'll be able to witness the eclipse
slightly wider and slightly lighter of a
shadow of the moon is known as the
penumbra that's what we're going to see
traveling across the Earth today and all
of us who are lucky enough to be under
it will witness the eclipse to some
degree
now the other type of eclipse you can
get as well as total and partial is an
annular Eclipse so that is when the moon
is further away in its orbit from the
earth so you end up getting that ring of
fire but today it's going to be a
partial solar eclipse globally because
the darkest part of the Moon Shadow it's
Umbra is going to miss the Earth
entirely it's going to fly over the
North Pole so no one on the globe today
is going to see a total solar eclipse
but the the question naturally arises if
the moon is orbiting around the earth
pretty much once every month then why
don't we see total solar eclipses or
Eclipses of any kind every single month
well the reason for that is because the
moon's orbit is tilted at an angle of
approximately five degrees as you can
see here in this rather simple graphic
where nothing is to scale here but it
gives you a bit of a better idea as you
can see the moon's uh orbit it's not
always aligned with the plane of the
Earth's orbit around the Sun that
invisible line known as the ecliptic so
we're not always going to get a perfect
crossover a perfect blockage of the
Sun's light
though around twice a year we do get
that line up perfectly so we usually get
a minimum of two solar eclipses every
year though sometimes we can get as many
as five in one calendar year now well
the last time that happened was all the
way back in the 1930s and that won't
happen again until the 2200s so it's a
bit of a long wait to get five eclipses
in one year but now no matter where
you're watching from today we're going
to bring you the best view of the
eclipse that we can but let's have a
look to see if today you will be able to
view the eclipse for yourself let's take
a look at the map of the world that'll
show us the coverage for today courtesy
of our friends over at timeanddate.com
now you can see the shaded areas here if
you fall underneath one of these areas
you will be able to see the eclipse to
some degree so as you can see it's
mostly large areas of Europe as well as
Central and South Asia but as well as
that even Greenland Iceland and and
parts of Northeast Africa will get a
chance to see some of the eclipse today
and within the Shadows you can see
really the further east you go the
better your chances are of seeing more
coverage
so one of the best places to view the
eclipse from today in fact is further
east Kazakhstan is one of the best
countries to view the eclipse from today
and in fact we've got a little bit of a
forecast here of just a few major
Capital Cities
across the globe just particularly
choosing ones with varied amounts of
coverage today so Astana in Kazakhstan
is one of the best Capital Cities to
view the eclipse from today and
surrounding regions you're looking at
about 78 coverage of the Moon across the
Sun so you're going to end up at maximum
with a very thin Crescent sun it's going
to be quite Spectacular Now that is
about just above the threshold above
which you will notice the sky getting
darker so in parts of Kazakhstan and the
parts of Russia directly north of
Kazakhstan you are going to notice the
sky getting noticeably darker and things
getting noticeably colder as we move
further west into Europe Helsinki and
surrounding areas of Finland looking at
about 54 coverage so that's rather good
you're going to see a slightly thicker
Crescent Sun but still going to be
rather spectacular moving further west
and slightly South Berlin surrounding
areas of Germany as well looking about
one-third coverage of the Moon across
the Sun so a rather significant bite
taken out of the sun this morning and
then further west still Paris and the
surrounding areas of France between 10
and 15 coverage
so that's across the globe and yes the
further east you go across Europe and
into Asia you're typically going to get
a better view but what about the UK what
are our prospects for today well let's
take a look at the forecast again
looking at Capital Cities
London here in Greenwich as well and
just the surrounding areas we're looking
at about 16 coverage so we're looking at
a sizable chunk taken out of the sun
this morning though certainly not enough
for it to get noticeably darker or
really that cold either moving further
west we can see Cardiff surrounding
areas of Wales about 12 percent coverage
and moving up north to Edinburgh about
19 and then as we move over to the West
over to Belfast and parts of Northern
Ireland you're looking at about 15
percent now do not worry if you're in
one of those areas where the percentage
is a little bit less because the truth
is the difference between 12 and 19 it's
really not going to be that noticeable
unless you are using very sensitive
solar viewing equipment so it's really
not worth getting in the car and
traveling East for a few extra percent
you're really not going to notice that
much of a difference now I believe we
are now at first Contact of the Sun or
of the Moon crossing over the Sun so
let's take a look at our view through
the anemonda astrographic telescope to
see what we can see
and yes there we are we have seen the
moon as it is now beginning the partial
solar eclipse we're looking at uh well
we're looking at our very own natural
satellite as it passes across the face
of the sun rather spectacular one of the
things you can begin to notice actually
is you can actually see uh different
lunar terrain you can see the rugged
Luna topography in action because the
moon itself it is not this smooth
marble-like object it is rugged there
are Hills there are valleys and that is
what we're beginning to see already we
are seeing Hills and Valleys already so
an exciting view already to kick things
off but we're going to be bringing you
that view of the eclipse throughout the
uh our coverage today
now we are viewing the eclipse today
through our Annie maunder astrographic
telescope but what is the animal
astrographic telescope how does it work
and how are we bringing you the view of
the solar eclipse today well to tell you
more here is Royal Observatory
astronomer Anna Gammon Ross
hello everyone my name is
at the Royal Observatory Greenwich I'm
here in the altazimuth Pavilion today to
show you the equipments we're going to
be using to view the partial solar
eclipse and that is our Annie maunder
astrographic telescope
the telescope is named after an Irish
astronomer Annie maunder who worked here
at the observatory in the late 19th
century
our anemonda astrographic telescope is
made up of four modern telescopes all
stuck together and in particular we're
going to be using just one of those
today the Lunt solar telescope
the lint soloscope has a four inch
aperture which is the diameter of the
objective lens at the end of the
telescope this may seem small but the
sun is close enough and bright enough
that this should do the job
the little telescope is specifically
designed for solar observing so this
means if we point it directly at the sun
it won't do any damage to the telescope
one thing that we cannot stress enough
is that you should never point a normal
telescope or binoculars directly at the
sun you should always use specialist
solar observing equipments and even then
you do need to be careful
our telescope becomes equipped with two
key filters to help us observe the Sun
the first is a blocking filter to reduce
the amount of light that we see from the
soap the second is a hydrogen Alpha
filter so it helps us to see just a
narrow bandwidth of visible lights
this helps us to see certain features on
the sun's surface such as sunspots and
solar prominences which are huge Loops
of glowing plasma that extend out beyond
the sun's surface
in order for us to show you the eclipse
we have a camera inserted into the
viewing end of the telescope instead of
a conventional eyepiece this camera is
connected to our computers that are then
broadcasting our view so you can see the
eclipse
so whether you are joining us from here
in the UK overseas or even outer space
stick with us to see the best of the
partial solar eclipse from here at the
Royal Observatory Greenwich
Anna Gammon Ross there showing us the
Annie maunder astrographic telescope
which is actually just above my head
just out of shot and we're going to be
viewing the eclipse today using that
bringing you the best view that we
possibly can now if you are just tuning
in welcome you are watching the Royal
Observatory greenwich's coverage of
today's partial solar eclipse my name is
Jake Foster and I will be your host for
this morning as together we witness the
partial solar eclipse and the weather
here in Greenwich today so far is pretty
good the forecast is a little bit mixed
but will bring you the best view that we
can now let's take another view through
the anemonder astrographic telescope as
we can see the moon now the eclipse
fully in action as it moves across the
face of the sun now the Moon is moving
about one kilometer every second so it
is absolutely zooming through space
right now even though it looks like a
slow crawl it really is zooming its way
across space and now while we are
viewing this we do have a few quests
questions from viewers that have come in
so we'll answer a few of these the first
question that's come in is will it get
noticeably darker in the UK the short
answer is no because only about 16 of
the Sun's light will be blocked out that
is not sufficient enough for us to
really notice it getting darker at all
here so that's not really going to
happen here you're going to need at
least 70 percent coverage usually before
you notice the difference another
question here when will the next total
solar eclipse be in the UK ah this one
will be a little bit of a weight it
won't be until
2090 that we see another total solar
eclipse here in the UK so a little bit
of a weight though that being said there
will be a fantastic partial solar
eclipse in 2026 and for that here in the
UK we're going to see about 90 percent
coverage so that's going to be really
rather good it will get noticeably
darker for that one
now if you would like to view the
eclipse for yourself today there are a
few ways that you can do it but the
first word of warning is that you should
not look directly at the sun with the
naked eye you will need specialist solar
viewing equipment to do it
now there are a few different ways that
you can view the eclipse today either
directly or indirectly so for example
well this is the view for a pair of
solar eclipse glasses and in fact if you
do have a pair of these this is the
ideal way to view the eclipse now if you
do have a pair of these they might look
a little bit like this or you may have a
solo viewer that looks like this they
work in the exact same way you may have
these stored away in a draw from a
previous solar eclipse now these work
because they have a black polymer filter
in them now that filter is basically a
flexible resin that is infused with
carbon particles and all of that
together blocks out
99.999 of the visible light coming from
the Sun as well as 100 of the
ultraviolet light and 100 of the
infrared light as well and that means
that when you're wearing these it is
safe to look up at this done and in fact
when you put them on as you just saw
from that image there
when you put them on you notice you
actually can't see anything at all right
now I can't see a thing the only thing I
would be able to see was the sun because
that is the only thing that's going to
be bright enough to penetrate through
these filters
so if you've got a pair of those before
you use them there are a couple of
checks you need to make to make sure
that they are working and that they are
suitable to use the first thing you need
to check is that they are ISO certified
so you're going to look for a little
logo a little ISO logo that's the
International Organization for
standardization who just make sure that
these are things are up to the correct
safety standards and as well as that a
CE certification also is a very good
sign so once you know you've got a
certified piece of Kit the next thing
you're going to need to do is actually
check the filters themselves you're
going to want to look for things like
tears punctures or even very large
creases which may have affected the
Integrity of the filter which means they
might not be safe to use anymore but if
they are all okay and none of those
punctures or tears or large creases then
they are safe to use make sure you put
them on before you look up at the Sun
and then look up look down before you
take them off again and you should limit
continuous use to about three minutes at
a time because even then staring at the
sun through these for too long is not a
great idea so about three minutes at a
time maximum but let's say maybe you
don't have any of this lying around the
house and you don't have a solar
telescope and you don't have a pair of
solar binoculars either well there are a
few choices for you that you can still
use to view the eclipse just indirectly
so one thing you can do is build your
very own solar projector and in fact I'm
going to have my blue Peter moment here
I'm going to show you how you can do
this to build your own solar projector
to project the eclipse all you need
actually is two pieces of paper
preferably card because it's a little
bit more rigid but two pieces of paper
will work absolutely fine what we're
effectively going to do is recreate the
conditions of a cinema here just without
all the popcorn and the sticky drinks so
this sheet of paper is going to act
basically as your cinema screen and this
one is going to be your projector to
make your projector all you need to do
is put a small hole in the center of the
piece of paper like so now this hole
doesn't need to be more than a few
millimeters in size but try to make it
as circular as you possibly can so once
you've got that all you need to do is
head outside turn your back to the Sun
so that you're not facing it hold up
your projector and project the eclipse
onto
your screen and you should be able to
see the image of the eclipse as it
happens so you'll see the byte taken out
of the sun you're going to want to hold
these approximately 30 centimeters apart
from one another if you want a larger
image simply separate the screen from
the projector if you want a smaller more
focused image just lower the distance
but let's say you don't even have two
pieces of paper to rub together well one
thing you may have lying around the
house is a piece of kitchenware that I
will show you right now it's this a
colander or a spaghetti strainer pasta
strainer whatever you call it
this actually is a pinhole projector in
its very own right basically it acts in
the exact same way turn your back to the
sun hold it up high so you can project
the image of the eclipse down onto the
ground or onto a screen a piece of paper
the only difference is going to be that
you're going to get a few dozen
projections rather than just the one but
let's say you don't even have a colander
but you don't have two pieces of paper
either you've got nothing you've got no
equipment lying around that you can use
hopefully you have something but one
thing you can use is your very own hands
as this image shows one thing you can
use to project the eclipse is just your
hands just cross over your fingers and
if you do it just right you can project
the eclipse onto the ground or onto a
piece of paper or even then
let's say you don't even want to do that
sometimes the trees make very good
pinhole projectors effectively the tiny
little gaps between the leaves in the
trees can act as pinhole projectors and
they will project the image of the
eclipse onto the ground but remember
when it comes to these pinhole
projectors or pinhole cameras camera
obscura whatever you want to call it you
need to remember that you do not look up
towards the sun through the projector
you look away from the sun down towards
your screen or down towards the ground
it is not safe to look up at the sun
again unless you've got special solar
eclipse glasses or solar viewers now one
person who loved eclipses and actually
used them for research purposes over 100
years ago was Annie maunder but who was
Annie maunder we've been mentioning her
name a few times so far who was she and
what did she do well to answer those
questions and more I sat down with the
senior curator of the Royal Observatory
Greenwich Louise devoy
will have heard the name Annie maunder
quite a bit so far but who exactly was
Annie maunder and what role did she play
here at the observatory well to help me
answer those questions and more I am
delighted to be joined by the senior
curator of the Royal Observatory
Greenwich Dr Louise devoy Louise thank
you for joining me thanks Jake so let's
begin with that question who exactly was
Annie maunder and what role did she play
here sure so Annie maunder or Annie
Scott Dill Russell as she was originally
known was from Northern Ireland and she
was one of five women recruited here at
the world Observatory to help with a
major new photographic project in the
1890s
the idea was that the observatory was
part of a network of around 20
observatories or so each one allocated a
certain part of the sky that could be
compiled together into a photographic
Atlas
now as you can imagine it was a very
ambitious project that requires a lot of
work and lots of support and so the
astronomer Royal William Christie along
with many other Observatory directors
realized that he could hire women as a
cheap and effective way to get this
project done without affecting the main
work of the observatory in measuring
time by the stars and so these so-called
lady computers started in 1890 and Annie
started a couple of months later in
September 1891. we don't know the exact
details of her training and observations
but at some point it seems that she was
transferred across to the heliographic
department where she became an expert in
photographing and cataloging sunspots
and that's really become a key part of
her story now you mentioned the role of
Lady computers there and all of this was
happening happening around the late 19th
and early 20th centuries what sort of
struggles would Annie have faced as a
woman in astronomy at that time and how
would that have affected her career
Journey yes Annie really faced many
struggles even before she started here
at Greenwich so one of the major hurdles
was educational recognition for her
achievements so for example she studied
at Gerson College Cambridge she did
exactly the same courses and exams as
the male students but she was not
awarded a degree because that was not
the the case for women at that time
she also struggled to get any
professional recognition the main
Organization for professional
astronomers back then and still today is
the Royal Astronomical Society but sadly
women were not permitted to be members
in the 1890s
so Annie and several of her colleagues
here at Greenwich both male and female
were actively involved in the formation
of the British astronomical Association
which was open to anyone with an
interest in astronomy male or female
amateur professional and that's still
very active today
and then finally there was also sort of
social barriers in a sense that married
women were not permitted to work in
government organizations so when Annie
decided to marry water mosa in December
1895 she had to give up her job here at
the observatory so it really just a
whole series of barriers and challenges
to getting involved in astronomy at that
time absolutely now you mentioned Walter
there and in 1908 Annie and Walter
published a book together in fact
we do have it here the heavens and their
story which they published together
though in the preface Walter does say
that this work is almost wholly the work
of my wife and this book contains many
wonderful images that Annie took of the
Sun
what do you think was the intention
behind this book and what do you think
it meant to them to be able to publish
this yes this book is really a great
example of annual water maunder's
passion and enthusiasm for astronomy and
as you say water acknowledges his wife
in the preface they also say that this
is not meant to be a textbook it's not
too serious or too heavy it's very much
about inspiring you to take an interest
in astronomy and to learn more as you go
along
and what I really like is that it's very
accessible and they just Clearly say you
don't need any fancy equipment you just
need your eyes and a sense of wonder to
enjoy the subject
now as you can see it's lavishly
Illustrated as well it's got color
plates it's got about 50 different
illustrations
um and it takes the reader on a journey
starting off with thinking about what
you can see in the sky so those basic
motions of the stars then you go through
the solar system the sun moon and
planets and then it goes out to think
about Nepali and the Milky Way so it's a
very comprehensive overview of the
subject and what I really like is it's
got a very Personal Touch in a sense
that the language is very much based on
any water mourners very devout Christian
beliefs there are various references to
the Bible and to the the sense of wonder
of God's creation so it has a really
nice touch I like it yeah fantastic and
you really can feel the passion sort of
radiating off of the page as you read it
now it is rather apt that we're going to
be viewing a solar eclipse through a
telescope that's named in Annie's honor
what role did eclipses play in Annie's
life and work look eclipses really were
a major part of Annie's life and work
after her marriage to Baltimore so by
now she wasn't an amateur astronomer
very much involved with the British
Association or the baa as we call it
call it and Annie Walter went on about
five different Eclipse Expeditions
heading off to Norway India Algiers
Mauritius and Canada and this provided
Annie with an opportunity to use and
sort of fine-tune her photographic
skills that she'd acquired here at
Greenwich
now even just six months after her
marriage she acquired a grant to
purchase a wide-angle lens for a camera
and she intended to use this to
photobuck the Milky Way because you want
to see a large part of the sky at once
but she realized that she could actually
use this for eclipses as well and she
was absolutely right on the 22nd of
January 1898 she took a photograph of
the eclipse as seen from India and the
photograph really captures these huge
coronal streamers these Jets have
charged particles from the solar
atmosphere and it said that when Annie
displayed her photograph to the baa the
whole audience erupted into Applause
because everyone recognized how
difficult and how pioneering this
Photograph was so Annie continued to
hone her skills using a whole
combination of different telescopes and
cameras and lenses just like we do today
and she really cemented her reputation
as a solo photographer
fantastic just to finish off what would
you say is Annie maunder's Legacy in
astronomy well on a simple level we have
her cast
which I'm
pleased she was actually allowed to
publish in her own name in 1907 fully
endorsed by the astronom oil so that
meant other astronomers could use her
data on a more subtle level we know from
her letters that she was actually
involved with the creation of the very
famous butterfly diagram so this was
published in brown 1904 and you plot the
position of the sunspots on the solar
disk according to their latitude and
over the course of the solar cycle you
can see how the sunspots appear at high
latitudes and then gradually lower and
lower towards the equator and he gets
very distinctive butterfly pattern now
this is a really iconic diagram within
solar physics it's still very relevant
today it's signed by Edward Morgan
Edward waltonwanda but at least we know
from the archives that Annie was very
much involved in that and we also know
from some of her Eclipse observations as
well that she described effects that are
now known and described the solar
physicists so really great to have that
Legacy enduring still sort of powering
through us today
and I think just on a personal level I
just find her story so fascinating and
it's really humbling when you think
about all those challenges that she
faced and that in itself I think is a
challenge for us to make the most of the
opportunities that we have fantastic uh
yeah absolutely and hopefully in some
small way the Annie maunder astrographic
telescope will help to carry on her
Legacy in some small way
but we do hope to capture something
great through the telescope but
obviously probably nothing quite as
amazing as what Annie captured in the
past Dr Louise devoy thank you very much
thank you Jake
that was Dr Louise devoy senior curator
of the Royal Observatory Greenwich now
let's take a look back at the Annie
maunder astrographic telescope because
we are now approaching maximum we're
more than halfway approaching maximum
maximum now in around 20 minutes time
what we're beginning to see now is even
more of the Moon as it passes over the
surface of the Sun and again one of the
things that stands out is that rugged
lunar terrain that we are seeing there
we're seeing the Hills and Valleys on
the western limb of the moon or in fact
not the Western limb we're looking more
at the the southern regions but one of
the I mean there's lots of Hills and
Valleys on the moon the largest mountain
on the moon is called mons Huygens it's
about five kilometers high so it really
is not this very smooth marble the Moon
is Lumpy and bumpy and again as it moves
across the sun we are seeing this now
you might notice here on the feed we're
getting a bit of wibbly wobbly waviness
now that is no fault of the Sun or the
Moon that is in fact our atmosphere
effectively what we are looking through
right now is about 100 kilometers of
water molecules or a lot of them so it
is like looking up into the sky through
a swimming pool so things do appear a
little bit wibbly wobbly but now we are
getting that lovely uh bite taken out of
the sun it is clear to see and as we
approach maximum we are only going to
see that more and more as we build
towards about 16 coverage here in
Greenwich and depending on where you are
across the UK you may might see as many
as or as much as 20 22 23 coverage so
it's going to be a fantastic view across
the country today and across the world
of course if you are further east you
may get as high as 80 percent coverage
you will notice the sky getting darker
now just while we are viewing the
eclipse here we will answer a few
questions that have come in
one of the questions is how do all the
planets and moons travel in such precise
predictable orbits well there's a few
different things to unpack there firstly
not all of them are well not all of them
are stable that's worth saying some
objects are on very unstable orbits so
the ones that are don't tend to hang
around for very long they usually crash
into things or end up flying out of the
solar system at a rate of knots how are
they so predictable well we've got
centuries worth of physics to thank for
that we've got Isaac Newton we've got
Albert Einstein and just hundreds if not
thousands of incredible
physicists that have helped us to
predict these because yes the Moon's
motion is entirely predictable in fact
we know when solar eclipses are going to
happen for the next hundred years to
incredible Precision so we know
everything that's going to happen in
advance I mean not everything but we
know where those objects are going to be
in hundreds of years time
another question come in why don't solar
eclipses happen every month and either
new or full moon well as we heard
earlier the moon's orbit is tilted at an
angle of five degrees so it does not
always align with that invisible line
connecting the Sun and the Earth so
we're not always going to get eclipses
every month and as well they're always
going to be at the new moon phase
because that is when well from our
perspective we can't see any of the far
of the near Side of the Moon because it
will be in darkness overwhelmed by the
brightness of the sun though at Full
Moon we do get different types of
eclipses we do get lunar eclipses at
Full Moon that's when the moon enters
into the shadow of the earth instead we
end up getting what is commonly known as
a blood moon so that is a type of
eclipse that does happen at full moon
but it is not solar
now the eclipse here is in full swing
the moon rocketing its way across the
face of the sun about three and a half
thousand kilometers every hour so it's
moving about the length of its diameter
every single hour so it's an incredibly
fast moving object even though when we
look up in the sky it looks rather
static it is moving contrary to uh well
other stars around it if it is in the
night sky as the Moon is moving
anti-clockwise around the earth so in
our skies it is moving from west to east
while the Sun and things like stars and
other things like that they're all
moving
east to west relative to where we are
one more question here uh would you be
able to see a solar eclipse from the
International Space Station and how
would it look the short answer is yes
that certainly is possible as well as
that you can see a solar eclipse from a
high altitude aircraft as well the view
is rather incredible
so you certainly can just if you are
orientated in the correct way
but there we are the eclipse still
ongoing fantastic view that we have
through the animanda astrographic
telescope because luckily the weather is
still on our side at the moment and we
are very grateful for it now the
question might naturally arise to you do
we have eclipses on other planets is
that possible and the short answer is
yes in fact you can get solar eclipses
on other planets you can get a solar
eclipse on Mars for example and we have
an image here and in fact the as we can
see there just in the telescope feed the
clouds were starting to come over so now
is a good time to uh
talk a little bit about Mars instead so
this is Mars's largest moon Phobos as it
eclipses the sun it's not large enough
in the sky for a total solar eclipse
but just a partial one or you may even
call this annular of A Sort Phobos is
only 22 kilometers across so it is a
very small object but it is very close
to Mars only about 6 000 kilometers away
so it does appear rather large in the
sky as well as that the Sun appears much
smaller in the sky from Mars only about
two-thirds the size as we see it here
from the earth so it's a smaller object
to eclipse and there is Phobos one of
the two moons of Mars the other one
being demos only about 12 kilometers
across as you can see Phobos is small
misshapen looks like a potato the reason
for that is because it simply isn't
massive enough to make itself nice and
round under the force of its own gravity
but what about further out in the solar
system can we get solar eclipses from
Jupiter for example
the answer is yes we can what we're
seeing here is an image taken by NASA's
Juno spacecraft and what we're seeing is
the shadow of IO one of the Galilean
moons as it traverses across Jupiter now
Jupiter is a gas giant which means it's
got no solid surface for us to land on
or stand on so you can't really stand on
the surface and view it but if you were
hovering above the clouds in a spaceship
you would be able to see that and it
would be rather easy to eclipse the sun
from Jupiter since it's about five times
smaller in the sky since Jupiter is
about five times further away from the
Sun than we are here on the Earth
now uh turning our attention back to the
eclipse you can see we're still making
steady progress as we get now now a very
nice large bite out of the surface of
the Sun again a little bit of wibbly
wobbliness from the atmosphere and as
well as that the rugged lunar Terrain in
action we're seeing a few different
valleys here as well now those deep
sections on the moon those valleys a lot
of them are caused by collapsed Lava
Tubes you see on the moon a few billion
years ago lava was flowing around all
over the place and over time usually the
top and the sides of the lava flow would
solidify and then as the liquid lava
underneath would flow all the way
through suddenly you're left with a
hollow tube and over time those tubes
collapse inwards and what you're left
with is a rather deep valley so what
we're seeing sort of here and here and
here are basically those valleys many of
which will have been formed by those
collapsed Lava Tubes across the lunar
surface
now a lot of the Fantastic imagery we've
seen so far today have come courtesy of
some incredibly advanced technology but
nowadays what do modern solar
researchers do what tools do we use to
study the Sun and what Secrets still
remain well to find out more I had a
chat with Professor Lindsay Fletcher
from the University of Glasgow to find
out more
in times of old the sun was an unknown
mysterious object that we knew very
little about nowadays we know a lot more
about it thanks to centuries of
fantastic research
but in 2022 what do modern solar
researchers do and what mysteries about
the sun still remain well to answer that
question and many more I am delighted to
be joined by Professor Lindsay Fletcher
Lindsay is a professor of astrophysics
in the school of physics and astronomy
at the University of Glasgow as well as
being an Adjunct professor at the
Rosalind Center for solar physics at the
University of Oslo and she's a fellow of
the Royal Society of Edinburgh so
Lindsay thank you so much for joining us
well thank you very much for inviting me
Jacob oh our pleasure uh now the first
question that I'm really excited to ask
you is about your research because
you've done a great deal of research on
solar flares so for those who don't know
what is a solar flare and what made you
want to study them
okay so a solar flare is kind of as
simple as an explosion on the sun uh
which means that it's unpredictable it
is very intense and it's actually quite
short-lived and what we see is an
enormous burst of radiation
uh coming from the surface and the
atmosphere of the Sun and very often
along with that is what's called a
coronal mass ejection which is uh about
a billion tons of gas actually
electrified gas called plasma which is
leaving the surface of the Sun at about
a million miles per hour roughly
speaking now I study the radiation part
of this the the flare the flash of
intense burst of energy release that's
why I look at
fantastic and so what is your current
research focused in on and what
questions about the sun are you hoping
to answer okay so
um I'm concerned with the effects of a
solar flare on a particular part of the
solar atmosphere this is a bit called
the chromosphere and if you like if you
think about layers in the atmosphere of
the sunlight we have like layers in the
atmosphere the Earth
um the visible part that we see with our
eyes is called the Photosphere that's
where we see sunspots and so on and the
outer part is called the Corona That's
tenuous and hot in between is a narrow a
narrow layer when I say narrow it's
still about 2000 kilometers thicker but
a narrow highly structured very
complicated layer called the
chromosphere chromos is is uh Greek for
color and it gets that name because when
you see the chromosphere during a solar
eclipse it's got a beautiful dark pink
red kind of color now um flares have
very dramatic effects in the corona I
mean I'm sure that people watching this
Vote or they may have or they should go
and look at movies from the Solar
Dynamics Observatory of players when you
see all kinds of magic happening in the
corona but in fact most of the radiation
that's emitters and most of the
radiation that we understand the flare
from ISM it is in the chromosphere and
so I'm looking at that thin part of the
solar atmosphere and I'm using a
technique called spectroscopy where we
we split the light up using uh well it's
not a prism anymore it's a thing called
the diffraction grating into its
component wavelengths and look at the
spectral lines the emission lines and
absorption lines which are born and try
and work out what's happening in that
layer how fast is it moving how dense is
it how hot is it how quickly does it get
heated how turbulent is it so all of the
details of the chromosphere which will
tell us about how energy arrives in the
chromosphere and how it's dissipated and
what it does when it's get when it gets
yeah fantastic it sounds very complex
and like it might rely on some very
advanced modern technology to help
assist you in that research what kind of
tools do you use to help you research
the Sun
so at the moment I am using
um data from a spacecraft called the
iris spacecraft that stands for
interface region Imaging
spectrograph I think
I've probably got that wrong and the pi
will kill me for getting it wrong
because the Irish spacecraft and no this
is a it's a bobbias atmosphere and the
reason it has to be above the Earth's
atmosphere is because the radiation I'm
looking at is ultraviolet radiation and
that's a part of the wavelength the the
electromagnetic spectrum which is
absorbed by the Earth's atmosphere you
can't see it from the ground you know it
is the bad radiation that's the stuff
that bungee and gives you all kinds of
nasty diseases
um so I look at data from the spacecraft
which is above the atmosphere and I'm
looking at the ultraviolet part of the
spectrum so this is a a spacecraft which
orbits around the earth and it does
takes takes images takes pictures but it
also takes Spectra
um so that's what I'm using right now
mostly along with some other Imaging uh
spacecraft like the Solar Dynamics
observation space but I am very much
hoping very soon to get some data are
from a new ground-based telescope to
which telescope which is called the um
Daniel K inuyi solar telescope or
decased
and it is a when I say it's a four meter
telescope that means it's main Miller is
four meters across which is small by
astronomical telescope standards you
know where if you think about like the
extremely large telescope it's going to
be like 50 meters or something I can't
remember yeah um but for solar the solar
case it's big you know the sun's very
bright so you can do a lot with a four
beat the mirror and that just starts
taking science observations you know
within about the last
um year or so and we're hoping to get
some data from that very soon so again
I'll be looking at images and Spectra
but now in a part of the spectrum the
visible part which our eyes can detect
and so you can you can do it from the
ground
wow fantastic uh and a lot of it sounds
like the stuff of Science Fiction it's
so incredibly Advanced and exciting but
I mean in the past say 100 years ago of
course we didn't have anything quite
like that and solar astronomers like
Annie maunder for example would rely on
things like solar eclipses to study the
Lesser scene parts of the Sun but how
does that work how can a solar eclipse
be used to study the Sun
or it can it's still very important um
astronomers and solar astronomers still
get really excited when an eclipse is
happening and that is because of the
amazing Coincidence of the disc of the
sun having exactly the same apparent
size as the disc of the Moon and every
so often they call a line
um and that means that we can see uh we
block out the radiation from the bright
disk of the Sun and we can see the very
tenuous Corona and also we can see this
part I mentioned the chromosphere we can
see filaments and we can see prominences
and all kinds of lumps and bumps in the
chromosphere
um now we do have in space we have got
and also on the ground instruments
called coronagraphs which are kind of
like fake eclipses which are there all
the time but they just because of the
way the Optics works and the problem of
what's called diffraction which is the
bending of light around the edge of an
object
um you cannot look so close in you're
you can't go into like one solar
diameter you can't see just just at that
that edge it's more like two or one
point one or something like that so with
an eclipse
um if you like the the the the the the
the desk that the light is having to
bend around is very much farther away
it's the moon and so that effective
diffraction is not so important
and uh so we can see really close in uh
to to the surface of the of the sun and
the inner Corona and just
um make amazing uh observations of the
complexity in the inner Corona and you
just we just don't with again with very
high resolution from the ground with
instruments that we can control very
well and we still do a lot of valuable
science with eclipses even though
they're only very short
um even though they're only you know
about seven minutes maximum I forget the
exact number uh there's just bits of the
solar atmosphere that you cannot reach
any other way
wow fantastic so eclipses still can be
useful for researchers today yes they
can they can um and there's other things
that people do like for example
um there are Eclipse Chasers and planes
that try and you know track the path of
totality for as long as possible so that
they can get that view of the inner
Corona for as long as possible
um and also you can do things like um
capture the what we call the Dynamics
the movements and the inner Corona at
very very high tankade and it's very
very high
um uh frames per second if you like and
that's done also in eclipses people you
know go chasing them with their
scientific instruments again to look at
this the detail of the inner atmosphere
that you can't get elsewhere and you
know why is there in our atmosphere
important
it's big or the end of Corona important
it's because we think this is
um one of the places that the
acceleration of the solar wind starts
that the um uh the processes that heat
the solar Corona
is originally in this location so
there's there are scientific questions
that we can answer by looking at the
center part as well but
um
you know I suppose the other valuable
thing is just when a similar eclipse
happens everybody knows about it and
everybody knows about the Sun and solar
businesses get so excited just about
this phenomenon that they're able to see
um so it's got that that other value
um it's a really good way to help
educate people about the Sun and about
what's going on in the sun fantastic a
free piece of marketing
it is a free piece of marketing yes
indeed yeah except they often have to
fly to you know places like svalbard to
see it you know so in that sense yes uh
well from our end here at the Royal
Observatory I mean we'll feel lucky just
if we're able to see the partial solar
eclipse uh and hopefully the clouds uh
stay away
uh but for now I'll say well Professor
Lindsay Fletcher thank you so much for
joining us
you're very welcome and I fingers
crossed fingers crossed video clips as
well thank you very much thank you
bye-bye
there we go that's better well fingers
crossed seems to have done the trick
because we do have clear skies here in
Greenwich so let's take a look at our
feed through the anime astrographic
telescope uh
here we are so we are now approaching
maximum we're only about five minutes
away at this point so we are getting
close to that full 16
now one of the things in fact that makes
an eclipse here on the earth so special
because of course we do get eclipses on
other planets but the thing that makes
Earth so special is there is a beautiful
Cosmic coincidence and relationship
between the Moon and the Sun and that is
that the Moon is 400 times smaller than
the sun in terms of its diameter but
also by total chance it is 400 times
closer to us which does often make the
two appear almost perfectly the same
size in the sky that leads to perfect
coverage during total solar eclipses and
as far as we are aware we are the only
planet in the solar system to get
perfect solar eclipses like that where
you get full 100 coverage because out in
the solar system where things are in
fact we've just seen the clouds go over
now so in fact we're going to switch to
our feed from across the globe courtesy
of our friends over at timeanddate.com
and in fact so we're seeing the eclipse
from Norway here their maximum a little
bit higher than ours they're getting a
maximum of about almost 40 percent which
they are closely approaching as are we
fantastic of you from Norway here's our
view back in Greenwich we've got the sun
back once again the clouds have parted
but yes this beautiful Cosmic
coincidence where in fact as far as we
are aware we are the only planet in the
solar system to get perfectly sized
solar eclipses far out in the solar
system the sun is much smaller the moons
of the outer solar system can eclipse
the Sun but they're much bigger than the
Sun they're not the same size so you
don't get those perfectly sized eclipses
like we do here
but there we are slowly approaching
maximum now
and in fact the rugged lunar topography
that we are seeing in action these
beautiful little lumps and bumps showing
us the Hills and Valleys of the moon
really are special and in fact they
really uh come into their own stardom
during total solar eclipses we'll very
quickly show you an image from a total
solar eclipse taken in 2017 this was
seen over parts of North America and in
fact you're seeing just a few minutes
before totality and down at the bottom
left of the eclipse of the seven o'clock
position you are seeing what is known as
Bailey's beads so these are the last few
beads of sunlight shining through some
of the deepest valleys on the moon and
they're known as Bailey's beads since
they were first explained by the
astronomer Francis Bailey now on this
particular Eclipse As you move a few
minutes closer to totality you get
another image of another phenomenon
caused by that rugged lunar topography
that we can show you now where we see
just one bead of light remaining through
the deepest lunar valley on that limb of
the Moon and then we end up getting
what's known as the diamond ring effect
so we are seeing the deepest valley that
last bead of light shining through and
you get what looks like a rather large
diamond on a beautiful ring as we see
there around the outside of the Moon and
then a few moments after that we get
totality of a total solar eclipse and
then the lunar topography sort of leaves
our mind behind and our eyes are
instantly drawn to the solar Corona the
thin wispy outer atmosphere of the Sun
that we heard about earlier now that
stretches millions of kilometers out
from the sun's surface and in places is
over one million degrees Celsius that's
hotter than the surface of the sun which
is about me five and a half thousand
degrees on the outer surface the reason
for that is still not fully understood
uh but that is part of the work of the
Parker solar probe that is currently
whizzing its way around the Sun as we
speak
so we've got a fantastic view still we
are steadily in fact we are bang on
maximum right now this is 16 coverage
from here in London across the globe
where you are those times are going to
differ across the UK they're only going
to differ by a few minutes so depending
on where you are in the UK you may have
had maximum a couple of minutes ago or
you're going to have it in a couple of
minutes time but this is it we are
seeing the Clockwork of the solar system
in action we were able to accurately
predict when these events were going to
happen many many years ago and we will
continue to do that into the future but
this is it we are seeing our very own
natural satellite the moon as it passes
over the sun blocking 16 of its light
from our perspective this is incredible
and again we're seeing those subtle
little shapes on the moon as well that
ordinarily we're just not able to see if
we look up into the moon or look up into
the sky to take a look at the moon so
this is really rather incredible we are
bang on maximum eclipse and remember if
you want to view this for yourself at
home you're going to need solar eclipse
glasses or specially specialized solar
equipment things like solar telescopes
solar binoculars things like that if you
want to project the eclipse safely onto
the ground you can use a pinhole
projector and remember do not look at
the sun through sunglasses that is not
sufficient to block out enough of the
Sun's light you're going to need solar
eclipse glasses Sunglasses tend to block
out only 20 percent of the sun's visible
light so that is just not good enough
and it looks like the clouds have
descended or just a patch just a patch
so in fact it's gone
and it's gone but that's okay because
well we've got other things to discuss
and we will come back to this view in
just a little while but here at the
Royal Observatory we absolutely love
Astro photography as you might be able
to tell some of the Fantastic images
we've been looking at today we love
astrophotography so much in fact that
every year we run the astronomy
photographer of the Year competition
where the best astrophotographers from
around the world submit their entries
into the competition now one of the
categories of that competition is the
Annie maunder prize for image Innovation
where entrants are challenged to take
publicly available data and transform it
into something new and captivating
so what goes into a winning image for a
category like that well let's take a
look and see
[Music]
my artwork is a relationship between Sky
time place and astronomy
clearly interested into our relationship
to our ancestors and how they would have
perceived the night sky
trees are a map to our past and there's
been scientific research in tree rings
and how they can show an element called
carbon 14 and so I was interested in
this in terms of that link between us
being made of carbon and also the time
element of tree rings I kind of started
looking at solar data online and was
just like gosh there's all this
information that you can pull down and
start creating things with and I just
thought well we're at the beginning of
solar cycle 25 what would it look like
if I took an image from the first of the
month until I don't know February of
2020 warm and laid them how would that
look and it started to look like the
rings of a tree I wanted to be a
scientist when I was a Youngster and I
didn't follow that pathway
so being shortlisted and then winning
the category is an amazing achievement
for me and hopefully inspiring other
women and other girls to look up at the
night sky and if you've got that
Creative Flair go with it it's a really
important journey and it's one that's
really really worth taking
foreign
[Music]
tree what a beautiful image and a
well-deserved winner now if you're
interested in taking a closer look at
that image and all of the other
wonderful short limit shortlisted images
from the competition then the astronomy
photographer of the exhibition is
currently ongoing at the national
Maritime Museum here in Greenwich as
well as that you can buy the book so you
can have all of those fantastic images
to take home with you as well now we are
just a few minutes past maximum now and
as we turn our attention to the anemonda
astrographic telescope lead we can see
that the clouds have finally descended
they are beginning to clear from time to
time but it looks like it's getting a
little bit thicker the clouds here in
Greenwich but luckily we did have a
fantastic view on maximum let's take a
look at the feed from across the globe
courtesy of our friends at
timeanddate.com
so here we are looking at Sienna in
Italy now their view of the eclipse is
looking rather Splendid isn't it they've
got rather clear skies where they are we
are very jealous indeed but they've got
a fantastic view there and they are
approaching maximum in fact pretty much
bang on there just a little bit more
than us here in Greenwich and what a
fantastic view here we've got our feed
once again the clouds have parted
but they are trying their best to hang
around they clearly like us but we don't
like them so clouds it'd be best if you
went away but there we are Siena in
Italy beautiful beautiful clear skies
and a fantastic eclipse look at that
beautiful bite taken out of the sun it
looks like Pac-Man yawning what a
beautiful sight to see
absolutely fantastic well we have just
passed over Maximum here in Greenwich so
in fact
what we are going to do in just a few
moments time is we are going to switch
over to a quiet stream which means you
will be able to continue to enjoy the
view of the eclipse but we're not going
to have any more live commentary or
coverage so before we go I'd like to say
a huge thank you to our collaborators
today Professor Lindsay Fletcher Dr
Louise devoy Anna Gammon Ross and our
friends over at timeanddate.com as well
a huge thank you to Dr Greg Brown who
has been diligently operating the
telescope all morning long and to our
team here at the Royal museums Greenwich
who have been helping to make all of
this happen and finally a huge thanks to
a huge thank you to all of you at home
for watching I've been Jake Foster
that's all from me and we hope you very
much enjoy the view and wherever you're
viewing from today we wish you all clear
skies thank you very much goodbye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm alive
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
never mind
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]